and again this is why like honestly guys
red pill seems like doomsdayers but I'm
telling you what is going to happen to
these retired only fans bottles what is
going to happen to these single mothers
they're gonna get together and they're
gonna live together and they're rather
die than live with the guy I mean it's
not like women as a whole are good with
money we make more money we we are in
debt and then we take money from the vet
and you know they'll live off a child
support until the kid's old but then
they'll still spend that money too
because women are women that's just what
we do and again guys this is just female
nature we're never happy we always want
better and you know we tend to wreck our
own homes that's why we really can't
have too much choice